Salut, moi, c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Ravi de vous retrouver cette semaine pour un épisode exceptionnel où je reçois la très distinguée Rokhaya Diallo, qui est journaliste et militante antiraciste.
Depuis Bruxelles et depuis Paris, on a discuté ensemble pendant 70 minutes des sujets sur lesquels elle a écrit plusieurs livres, à savoir entre autres choses, le racisme, l'universalisme français et les interactions entre les deux.
Rokhaya est quelqu'un de très occupé et je suis ravi qu'elle ait pu passer 70 minutes avec moi. C'est un épisode qui se veut abordable par les personnes qui ne sont jamais confrontées à ces questions-là,
mais aussi par ceux et celles qui connaissent déjà bien Rokhaya et qui sont intéressés de l'écouter raconter ses expériences dans les médias.
Quelques précisions avant de se lancer. Dans cet épisode, on parle bien évidemment de race en tant que construction sociale et pas du point de vue biologique.
Je préfère préciser d'emblée. Et enfin, si vous nous écoutez sans savoir à quoi nous ressemblons, sachez que Rokhaya est noire et que moi, je suis blanc.
Allez, c'est parti. J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Rokhaya Diallo. Rokhaya, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Rokhaya, tu es cofondatrice de l'association Les Indivisibles, tu es journaliste, autrice, militante antiraciste et féministe.
Tu apparais beaucoup dans les médias, y compris, par exemple, le Washington Post depuis peu et dans Touche pas à mon poste.
Donc tu fais un petit peu le grand écart à ce niveau-là. Et tu coanimes le podcast Kiffe ta race avec Grace Ly pour Binge Audio.
Est-ce que j'ai oublié quelque chose dans cette longue liste ?
Alors, je vais juste corriger, c'est Balance ton poste, l'émission.
Ah oui, OK. Au temps pour moi. Tu n'apparais jamais dans Touche pas à mon poste ?
Si, j'apparais aussi dans Touche pas à mon poste, mais j'ai d'ailleurs été chroniqueuse dans Touche pas à mon poste il y a deux, 'fin, il y a deux, trois ans.
Mais effectivement, cette saison, je suis chroniqueuse dans Balance ton poste. Mais ce sont, voilà, ce sont des émissions proches.
Les mêmes équipes, même boîte de production. Mais donc oui, tu es très active dans les médias et j'imagine que, au plus on parle de racisme, au plus on t'invite sur le plateau, en radio et...
Alors, c'est peut-être une question maladroite, mais est-ce que tu le vis bien, ça, d'être un petit peu devenue, et je vais mettre des gros, gros guillemets : « Madame antiraciste » ?
Est-ce que tu vis bien le fait que ta personne soit associée aussi fondamentalement aux questions de racisme et de, voilà, de parler surtout de ça, que c'est quelque chose que-
Alors-
...tu vis bien ? Ou est-ce que tu aimerais qu'on parle d'autre chose ?
Alors, c'est pour ça, je parle pas de ça 80 % du temps. Il me semble que dans la liste des médias que tu as énoncés, tu n'as pas parlé de LCI.
Donc je suis dans l'émission 24h Pujadas, c'est la troisième saison. En réalité, si on décompte mon temps de parole médiatique, je pense que 80 % du temps, je ne parle pas de racisme. J'ai été sur-
Ah, au temps pour moi.
Oui, c'est l'impression qu'on donne parce que c'est ce qui sort sur les réseaux sociaux, mais j'ai été éditorialiste dans l'émission On refait le monde sur RTL pendant 11 ans.
L'émission s'est arrêtée au mois de juin et sur 24h Pujadas, en réalité, on parle assez rarement de racisme puisqu'en fait, on parle de l'actualité quotidienne.
Donc c'est vrai que je parle beaucoup beaucoup de politique. Je parle de racisme volontairement dans les espaces que j'ai créés, comme Kiffe ta race, comme mes documentaires, comme mes réseaux sociaux, mais aussi de féminisme.
J'pense que j'en parle quasiment autant. Donc ça ne me gêne pas quand je choisis de le faire et ça me gêne pas que, ponctuellement, lorsque l'actualité l'exige, on me sollicite pour débattre de ces thématiques-là.
Mais en réalité, si on fait le décompte de mon temps de parole médiatique depuis 10 ans, je pense que j'ai passé l'essentiel de mon temps à commenter la vie politique française.
Eh ben voilà. Ben donc, au temps pour moi. C'est vrai que depuis la lointaine, la lointaine Belgique, je ne regarde pas évidemment
les émissions de LCI, donc j'ai effectivement plutôt accès à tes réseaux sociaux et à tes podcasts.
Mais donc, oui, ben, 'fin, on peut transformer la question. Est-ce que c'est un sujet que tu abordes avec facilité ?
Parce que voilà, ce que je pense comprendre, c'est que c'est-- on va plonger au cœur du sujet dans un instant, mais le racisme, construction sociale dont il est très difficile, voire impossible souvent, de s'extraire.
Et toi, en fait, finalement, tu fais le choix de te spécialiser là-dedans et d'en parler dans tes médias.
Alors, est-ce que c'est quelque chose que tu fais avec facilité ? Comment est-ce que ça se passe pour toi ?
Oui, en réalité, la question de l'antiracisme, des inégalités de manière générale, c'est une question qui m'intéresse beaucoup depuis très longtemps.
Et c'est vrai que mes premières prises de parole médiatiques étaient liées à la question du racisme, à la question de l'identité française.
Donc moi, je le fais vraiment avec beaucoup de facilité parce qu'en réalité, ce sont des sujets qui me passionnent, sur lesquels je me documente énormément parce que
ce sont des sujets en réalité fondamentaux et constitutifs de nos identités modernes.
L'expansion du racisme esclavagiste et colonial est liée à l'expansion du capitalisme et a structuré nos économies et la manière dont certaines populations ont été dispersées dans le monde.
Il y a des territoires qui n'existeraient pas tels qu'ils existent aujourd'hui, en tout cas sur le plan identitaire, s'il n'y avait pas eu l'esclavage.
Y a des populations, des civilisations, dont certaines font partie de la population
nationale française, qui n'existeraient pas si elles n'avaient pas été arrachées de manière extrêmement brutale au continent africain pour être
d'une certaine manière dispersées dans les Amériques.
Donc oui, c'est un sujet qui m'intéresse et je ne me sens pas acculée ou contrainte de l'évoquer
parce que je pense que c'est un sujet important qui est sous-exposé, je pense, en France en tout cas, dans un débat qui serait véritablement un débat intellectuel.
Donc je suis contente d'avoir l'opportunité de le faire. Et je sais que c'est très rare pour une journaliste française de pouvoir autant travailler sur les questions raciales et sur les questions de sexisme.
Et justement, plus spécifiquement par rapport à ta condition de
citoyenne française, puisque tu es née à Paris. La France, donc-- et on aura l'occasion d'en reparler, mais être très attaché à une certaine forme d'universalisme républicain, sans doute.
C'est sans doute le pays où c'est le plus le cas au monde. Et donc voilà, j'ai par exemple, je me souviens, je ne sais pas si tu avais pu voir cette vidéo.
C'était il y a quelques années, un candidat d'extrême droite français aux élections présidentielles. Donc je me souviens même plus de son nom, mais c'était un petit candidat pour ainsi dire,
qui, voilà, défendait des thèses racistes, pardon.
Y avait par exemple dans son programme l'idée de, entre guillemets : « interdire la musique nègre » et ce genre de choses.
Et je me souviens qu'il y avait
un journaliste français noir qui était venu l'interviewer. Et c'était assez bluffant comment dans l'interview,
le journaliste français noir qui menait cette interview reniait le fait qu'il était noir et c'était : « Ah non, mais moi, je ne me considère pas comme un Noir, je suis français ».
Dans votre programme, je vous cite : « Vous voulez bannir la musique nègre ».
Je veux simplement qu'on mène une politique culturelle identitaire et par conséquent que les médias publics promeuvent la musique française ou occidentale, pas la musique nègre.
Qu'est-ce que vous considérez aujourd'hui, en 2016, comme musique nègre ?
La musique nègre, c'est l'expression de l'âme des populations de race congoïde. Les Blancs sont les caucasoïdes, les Noirs d'Afrique sont les congoïdes.
Parce que vous parliez que ça peut conduire à l'ensauvagement.
Il y a une obscénité latente. La musique nègre est très chargée de sexualité, de sexualité. Le rythme de la musique nègre est sexuel.
Vous prônez dans votre programme le racisme positif-
Oui, bien sûr.
...sans haine. Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Quand on parle de racisme, on pense à la haine. Bon. Et moi, la haine est un sentiment que j'ignore. Seulement, il y a un autre aspect des choses qui est la conscience raciale, la conscience de race.
Ça, c'est le racisme positif. Et qui consiste d'abord à constater qu'on est de la même race que quelqu'un d'autre.
Et ce ne sont pas les Noirs qui vont me reprocher cela, parce que la conscience de race est très forte chez les Noirs.
Et vous le savez mieux que moi. Elle est très forte chez les Noirs.
Chez les Noirs, peut-être, moi, je sais pas.
Ah ouais. Bon écoutez, ne soyez pas de mauvaise foi. Elle est très forte.
Très sincèrement, moi, je ne m'inscris pas en tant qu'homme noir. Je suis pas né en me disant : « Je suis noir ». Ça, c'est vraiment, je vous le dis avec la plus grande des sincérités.
Moi aussi. Moi, je suis né en disant que j'étais français, mais pas en disant que j'étais-
Donc la notion que moi, j'essaie de mettre en avant ma race ou des choses comme ça, c'est-- j'ai grandi-
Vous savez très bien que beaucoup de personnes de race congoïde, des Noirs si vous préférez, pour parler plus simplement,
ont une conscience de race très aiguë, ce qui en soi ne me gêne pas, sauf lorsqu'elle se transforme en haine à l'égard des Blancs.
Il reniait le fait qu'il était noir et c'était : « Ah non, mais moi, je ne me considère pas comme un Noir, je suis français ».
Ce sont des sujets qui sont globalement très difficiles à aborder en France. Et avant même de vouloir les aborder, il y a la question de démarrer cette démarche, démarrer ce combat.
J'ai l'impression que c'est pas hyper intuitif pour de nombreux Français et que de nombreux Français et Françaises sont très attachés à cet idéal universaliste républicain.
Comment expliquer que toi, citoyenne française, ça te soit venu aussi naturellement de délaisser cet idéal universaliste et de mener ce combat antiraciste de la manière dont tu le fais ?
Alors moi, le seul souvenir que j'ai d'entretien avec cet homme d'extrême droite et une personne noire, c'était avec
Lucien Jean-Baptiste qui est comédien, qui avait fait un documentaire sur les Noirs et lui qui avait complètement assumé le fait qu'il était noir.
Et d'ailleurs, je me souviens que quand ils avaient pris rendez-vous par voie téléphonique avec cet homme donc que j'ai même pas envie de nommer.
Et quand Lucien Jean-Baptiste a ouvert la porte, il était très surpris de voir que c'était un homme noir parce qu'effectivement, il s'appelle Lucien Jean-Baptiste et il s'attendait pas à une personne comme ça.
C'est ça. Bien sûr, bien sûr.
Et l'entretien était vraiment choquant, mais je trouvais qu'il avait été intéressant et que pour le coup, Lucien Jean-Baptiste est une personne qui s'est emparée de ce thème-là en tant que comédien noir, ce qui n'était pas si courant,
voilà, ce qui n'était pas si courant, même de manière générale, même si aujourd'hui, y a aussi pas mal de comédiennes, de femmes, qui le font, notamment Aïssa Maïga ou Nadège Beausson-Diagne.
C'est vrai qu'en France, c'est très difficile de s'emparer de la question du racisme. Et je pense que quand j'ai commencé à travailler cette question-là, je n'avais pas réalisé à quel point je m'en prenais à un tabou français.
C'est-à-dire que j'ai vraiment commencé à m'interroger d'abord sur les disparités nord-sud, donc sans vraiment me placer dans cette hiérarchie en termes de pouvoir économique.
Et puis je me suis intéressée au racisme par le biais d'événements qui se produisaient sur le sol français et notamment par le traitement médiatique de certaines actualités.
Mais quand je l'ai fait, j'imaginais pas du tout à quel point
ces questions pouvaient crisper. Et d'ailleurs, au début, j'étais accueillie avec beaucoup de bienveillance parce que quand j'ai commencé à m'exprimer sur le racisme, quand j'ai monté l'association Les Indivisibles avec d'autres,
à la fin des années 2000, milieu/fin des années 2000, le président était Nicolas Sarkozy, donc qui était un président de droite.
Et c'est vrai que notre discours a été plus perçu comme un discours contre la droite que comme un discours contre le racisme.
Et en réalité, notre discours antiraciste a été perçu comme problématique à partir du moment où on a commencé à pointer du doigt le racisme issu de la gauche.
Parce que la gauche française a une telle conviction de son antiracisme qu'elle est incapable de se remettre en question et d'accepter une critique frontale.
Là où à droite, on reconnaît que c'est de bonne guerre. Alors, ça veut pas dire qu'on accepte de reconnaître son racisme, mais les réactions sont différentes. Donc,
oui, effectivement,
j'avais pas conscience de ça quand j'ai commencé. Donc il m'a fallu quelques années pour me rendre compte que si je voulais poursuivre cette discussion sur le racisme, effectivement, il faudrait beaucoup de force et beaucoup d'acharnement.
Et là, ça a été-
Ça a été, ouais, ça a été une découverte assez brutale. Assez brutale, assez violente.
Et je me suis découverte, hein, y compris en termes de personnalité dans l'exercice, parce que j'imaginais pas que je pouvais faire preuve d'autant de volonté et d'autant de ténacité.
Je m'étais jamais projetée dans un exercice comme ça où je me, j'étais quand même, en tant que journaliste, très isolée.
J'imaginais pas que je pouvais persévérer autant pour faire entendre ce qui me semblait être la vérité.
Est-ce que l'idée de
remettre en question l'universalisme républicain, ça t'est venu tout de suite ? Ou bien est-ce que
tu as eu, genre, comme c'est souvent le cas, j'ai l'impression,
un certain temps de transition où d'abord on continue à rêver de cet universalisme où on est tous français, où y a pas de noirs, pas de blancs, ce sera peut-être pour plus tard.
Et puis, 'fin, le remettre en question de plus en plus. Comment ça s'est passé pour toi, cette transition ? Est-ce que c'était évident dès le début ?
Alors moi, c'est--
j'ai été élevée dans cette mythologie républicaine. C'est-à-dire que j'ai effectivement cru, étant jeune, qu'on était tous français, qu'y avait, oui, effectivement un peu de racisme, mais qu'il était marginal.
Là où j'ai compris des choses en travaillant, c'est que la République avait sciemment accompagné une idéologie raciale, une idéologie raciste qu'elle avait perpétrée,
dans ses colonies, au nom de la République, donc avec vraiment un grand écart entre les valeurs proclamées et les actes réalisés.
Et l'universalisme, je pense que je l'avais pas en tête de manière aussi claire. Mais c'est quand il a été invoqué que je l'ai, de manière-- parce que je pense qu'on n'en parlait pas tant que ça avant.
Mais il est, pour moi, il est apparu de manière concomitante avec la critique d'une forme de communautarisme. De ce fait, je n'ai jamais vraiment adhéré à cette mythologie.
Parce que pour moi, c'est une mythologie. C'est une mythologie qui a été convoquée pour nier aux minorités le droit de se penser comme telles.
Et elles se pensent comme telles parce qu'elles sont traitées comme telles. Donc c'est pas une invention. Et pour moi, je veux dire, l'appréhension de l'universalisme est venue en fait
assez rapidement avec la critique du communautarisme, en fait, qui pour moi est une fabrication des dominants pour disqualifier les minorités.
Parce que le communautarisme, en réalité, personne n'a de velléités séparatistes comme on l'entend beaucoup dire en France.
Les gens qui sont qualifiés de communautaristes ne font que réclamer l'application
des valeurs républicaines à tous les groupes,
ne font que réclamer le fait que chacun, chacune puisse se voir tout simplement appliquer des principes qui sont les valeurs proclamées dans la devise républicaine : liberté, égalité, fraternité.
Donc dans ça, y a pas de volonté de scission. Au contraire, y a une volonté d'inclusion. Et je trouve que c'est curieux de critiquer des gens qui ne font que réclamer le principe d'égalité.
Il me semble que c'était le président Emmanuel Macron qui parlait justement de ces Français qui veulent diviser la République.
C'est ça ? Je me trompe pas de citation ? Il avait dit quelque chose comme ça, il me semble.
Il parle de séparatisme. Oui, le--
'fin, il employait ce mot qui a été repris par la suite par Gérald Darmanin, ministre de l'Intérieur, et par Marlène Schiappa, qui est
secrétaire d'État, je crois, à la Citoyenneté, en tout cas qui dépend aussi du ministère de l'Intérieur.
En fait, pour moi, c'est retourner les dynamiques de pouvoir. Parce qu'en réalité, qui a la force de séparer ?
Qui a le pouvoir de se séparer en France ? Les personnes qui ont le pouvoir de vivre séparément des autres en France sont les personnes qui ont de l'argent, qui ont les moyens de vivre dans des ghettos de riches.
Et les gens qui vivent dans des ghettos urbains paupérisés ne le font pas de leur propre volonté. Si on donnait le choix aux personnes qui vivent dans des cités pauvres
où les ascenseurs sont en panne, où les services publics sont défaillants, ils demanderaient à vivre là où vivent les riches, là où vivent les proches d'Emmanuel Macron. Donc je trouve que
Emmanuel Macron, qui a démontré à plusieurs reprises combien il était coupé de la France et
des préoccupations quotidiennes des Français, je pense qu'il nourrit le séparatisme, mais il nourrit le séparatisme des nantis, le séparatisme des puissants.
Je pense qu'il y a aussi une forme de séparatisme dans l'exercice du pouvoir. Quand on voit le rapport du CSA, qui est le Conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel en France, qui chaque année,
nous explique qu'il y a une mauvaise représentation des minorités raciales et sociales dans les médias français, qui le fait chaque année depuis-- 'fin, en tout cas, qui l'a fait pour la première fois en 1999
et qu'il fait chaque année depuis le milieu des années 2000,
fait un constat autour duquel il n'y a pas beaucoup d'évolution.
Je pense que le séparatisme est là, hein. Le fait que certaines personnes s'octroient en fait une représentation, le droit à être représentées,
au détriment d'autres qui n'ont jamais de miroir réaliste de ce qu'elles sont dans les écrans.
Oui, je pense que là, effectivement, il y a matière à critiquer une forme de séparatisme. Mais encore une fois, pour moi, c'est retourner la responsabilité
vers des gens qui n'ont pas de pouvoir, qui n'ont absolument aucun pouvoir et qu'on stigmatise, qu'on pointe du doigt alors même qu'ils sont, qu'ils et elles sont les victimes.
On a beaucoup parlé de racisme systémique ces derniers mois. Plus qu'avant, il me semble. J'espère que je ne me trompe pas.
En particulier, donc, suite au meurtre de George Floyd par des policiers américains. Est-ce que toi, tu observes un shift, un changement dans le traitement médiatique des questions du racisme en France,
suite à ces actualités-là ?
Et j'inclus là-dedans également le meurtre de Adama Traoré.
Alors oui, je pense qu'il y a un énorme changement. Moi, je parle de ce racisme systémique depuis très longtemps. Dans mon premier livre « Racisme : mode d'emploi » qui est paru en 2011
et que j'ai écrit entre 2009 et 2010, je parlais déjà de racisme systémique.
Et je ne l'avais pas inventé. Cette question-là, elle a été, elle était déjà mobilisée
à la fin des années 60, début des années 70, voilà, par des militants, notamment des Black Panthers, qui parlaient du système raciste.
Donc c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas nouveau et qui est loin d'être le fruit de mon invention. Je pense que le débat a beaucoup évolué.
Il a beaucoup, beaucoup évolué. Qu'il y a eu un accélérateur en 2020 du fait de la mort de George Floyd et de la redécouverte, parce qu'Adama Traoré, malheureusement, est mort en 2016.
Donc la redécouverte de sa mort,
cette année, parce que comme un écho à ce qui s'était passé aux États-Unis, et que tout d'un coup ces actualités tragiques ont contraint les médias, et surtout les actualités tragiques et le succès des manifestations.
Parce qu'il y a une manifestation le 2 juin dernier devant le tribunal à Paris qui a mobilisé des dizaines de milliers de personnes, et ça a été un choc pour des médias qui n'étaient absolument pas préparés.
Y avait très peu de journalistes sur place et ça les a obligés à questionner
le racisme français. Et y a eu beaucoup de dénégations, ils se sont beaucoup débattus pour dire : « Oh non, la France n'a absolument rien à apprendre des États-Unis, nous sommes différents, etc.
» Mais malgré tout, ils étaient obligés d'aborder la question. Et ça, je trouvais ça extrêmement intéressant, extrêmement nouveau.
D'autres termes se sont imposés, le terme de privilège blanc qui a été débattu. Alors, c'est Christine, pardon, c'est Virginie Despentes.
Je sais pas pourquoi, je sais pas d'où m'est venu le nom de Christine. Je pense que je pensais à Christine Delphy, la féministe.
Mais c'est Virginie Despentes, la romancière qui a, au lendemain de cette manifestation, écrit une lettre pour France Inter où elle parlait du privilège blanc et de son privilège en tant que femme blanche.
Alors, elle a été extrêmement critiquée, de manière injuste selon moi, mais elle a fait entrer dans le champ médiatique ce terme de privilège blanc.
Encore une fois, moi, c'est un terme que j'utilisais déjà dans mon livre en 2010
et que d'autres avaient utilisé bien avant moi, cette question du privilège blanc, de la construction de l'identité blanche comme dominante qui n'est jamais questionnée dans le racisme.
On parle toujours des minorités, mais jamais de la majorité. Et je trouve que oui, y a eu... les médias se sont sentis contraints et obligés de parler de la question raciale.
Et quels que soient les termes qu'ils ont choisis, c'est pour moi un changement parce qu'ils étaient dans une position où ils ne pouvaient plus faire comme si cette question n'existait pas.
Et ils ont été aussi obligés de parler de violences policières racistes, et le ministre de l'Intérieur aussi a été contraint de s'exprimer sur la question et de questionner le racisme dans la police.
J'ai le souvenir d'un passage que tu avais fait, donc c'était, je crois, chez RTL, pour commenter donc cette actualité-là.
Et tu avais face à toi, je dirais des... je ne sais pas si c'était une journaliste ou une chroniqueuse, mais plutôt conservatrice sur ces thèmes-là.
Et donc voilà, il y avait, comme tu disais, une espèce de comparaison, de parallèle entre la situation aux États-Unis avec George Floyd et la situation en France avec Adama Traoré.
Et alors je crois qu'elle avait dit que c'était absolument pas comparable parce qu'Adama Traoré, il avait un joint sur lui et donc c'était presque justifié quoi.
C'est ce qui lui est arrivé, c'était assez horrible à écouter.
Est-ce que vous pouvez accepter qu'une partie de votre population, vos concitoyens, parce qu'ils n'ont pas la même couleur que vous, sont harcelés par la police et certains meurent.
Est-ce que ça, c'est acceptable dans notre pays ? Je pense qu'il faut... 'fin, je pense que c'est sur la sémantique qu'on sera pas d'accord.
Parce que moi, je considère que c'est pas la police. Je considère que ce sont des policiers, ce sont des individus-
Donc c'est pas institutionnel
...qui, comme beaucoup d'individus, eh ben ont des tares, ont des défauts et sont déviants. Mais on ne peut pas,
incriminer l'ensemble de l'institution, les gendarmes, les policiers et dire : « La police assassine » comme on l'a pu entendre.
Non, non, c'est pas dans votre bouche, mais on l'a entendu dans la bouche d'un certain nombre de personnes et considérer finalement que c'est institutionnalisé.
C'est faux. Dire que parce qu'on est de couleur, on risque d'être contrôlé davantage, c'est vrai. Dire qu'on risque d'être victime de violences policières, c'est faux.
Dès lors qu'on ne résiste pas, dès lors qu'on ne s'échappe pas à s'échapper pendant un contrôle de police, les choses se passent normalement.
Alors, si je peux, si je peux me permettre.
Allez-y, Rokhaya.
Alors, déjà, Adama Traoré est mort, de l'aveu des gendarmes, sous le poids de trois gendarmes sur le dos. C'est eux qui l'ont dit, c'est leur formulation.
C'est faux. Par ailleurs, Adama Traoré n'avait rien fait. Il n'avait pas sa carte d'identité. Si je... Dix-sept interpellations.
Il n'avait pas sa carte d'identité sur lui ce jour-là. Alors donc c'est une raison pour mourir sous le poids de trois gendarmes.
Et du cannabis aussi. Mais c'est incroyable de-
Mais ce n'est pas non plus une raison pour qu'il était-
Il avait 24 ans, il n'avait pas ses papiers d'identité, c'est pour ça qu'il est mort. Zyed Benna, Bouna Traoré sont morts dans un conteneur dans un... Rien à voir avec George Floyd, qu'on soit bien d'accord.
Le problème pour moi, c'est quand même qu'elles sont des, ce sont des... Alors, j'étais face à deux journalistes, alors un journaliste qui est Jean-Christophe Buisson et Laurence Saillad, qui est une militante, en fait.
En réalité, ce que j'ai découvert après, je ne connaissais pas bien son profil. Jean-Christophe Buisson, en fait, est...
Bon, je le connais depuis longtemps. On fait régulièrement des débats et c'est vrai qu'il interrompt énormément. Il m'interrompt tout le temps, tout le temps, tout le temps.
C'est-à-dire que lui, à chaque fois, moi, j'ai la politesse de laisser dérouler sa parole et il m'interrompt et je le signifie.
Et c'est marrant parce que lui, il est convaincu que c'est une posture de ma part, que je joue un jeu alors que ce sont les règles du débat.
Il l'a dit après sur Twitter et ça l'énerve à chaque fois que je lui dis : « Arrêtez de m'interrompre » parce que je pense qu'il y a quand même une dimension sexiste.
Et c'était d'autant plus choquant ce jour-là
qu'on parlait de racisme, c'est-à-dire qu'on avait comme ça des personnes blanches qui s'étaient exprimées et que la seule personne noire
qui était quand même concernée par cette question du racisme, parce que la peur de la police, c'est quelque chose
qui me traverse pas directement parce que je suis une femme, mais que je connais à travers l'expérience de membres de ma famille ou de mon entourage amical, et ben on m'interrompt comme si mon expérience, en fait, n'avait pas de valeur.
Et Laurence Saillad, en fait, elle m'a beaucoup choquée parce qu'elle a parlé d'Adama Traoré comme s'il n'était l'enfant de personne.
C'est une femme qui est mère de famille et c... moi, j'ai vu le processus de déshumanisation et sur le coup, j'ai senti quelque chose qui était gênant et j'étais, franchement, j'étais un peu paralysée.
Et quand elle a dit qu'en fait, en réalité, il aurait dû être en prison, c'était choquant parce qu'en réalité, ce qu'elle disait, c'est que ben en fait quand on est un homme noir, soit on est en prison, soit on est mort.
Et qu'elle a parlé de lui avec une forme de sourire qui m'a choquée parce qu'en fait, elle n'a même pas eu de compassion pour le fait qu'il soit mort.
Qu'il ait eu un casier. Déjà, ce jour-là, il n'était pas recherché. Donc je pense que c'est important. Il a été arrêté sans raison.
Qu'il ait eu par le passé un casier,
OK, certes, mais ça ne justifie en aucun cas le fait qu'il soit mort. Et le fait qu'elle n'ait pas fait preuve de sensibilité à ce moment-là, alors qu'on a vu sa sœur s'exprimer, je veux dire,
perdre un frère dans de telles circonstances, c'est tragique.
Ça veut dire qu'y a pas d'identification.
Et je pense qu'il n'y a pas d'identification parce que c'est un homme noir de banlieue et qu'à aucun moment, elle, elle a eu dans sa vie, cette femme, la crainte que ses enfants soient exposés à des violences policières.
Et c'est en ça que j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait une division et un regard qui était condescendant
Et tu disais donc c'est une militante, c'est-à-dire ?
C'est une militante en fait, oui, parce qu'elle est proche de mouvements qui se proclament, qui se disent laïques, mais qui en réalité sont très très très concentrés contre les expressions religieuses liées à l'islam.
Je me suis rendue compte-
Donc c'est genre le Printemps républicain, c'est genre ce truc-là quoi.
Oui, je pense qu'elle est un peu dans cette mouvance-là. Je sais pas de quelle organisation elle fait partie, mais elle est vraiment là.
Ouais.
Voilà, pour moi, elle fait partie de cette mouvance extrêmement agressive
à l'égard de l'expression culturelle ou cultuelle des personnes minoritaires en France et qui proclament la laïcité, mais qui en vérité ont une vision extrêmement identitaire de la République.
Une position qui n'est pas si rare dans les médias français, il me semble.
Elle est assez commune, oui.
Voilà, donc y avait évidemment cet aspect-là qui m'avait frappé, donc cet aspect, ben, on peut parler de racisme sans trop de peine, je pense.
Dans l'exercice du parallèle entre la situation aux États-Unis et la situation en France, y a du : « Oui, OK, y a une situation problématique, un problème systémique aux États-Unis, mais en France, pas de souci.
» 'fin, ici, le racisme presque... 'fin, on a presque l'impression qu'ils disent : « Ça n'existe pas ici ». Comment est-ce que toi, tu as perçu
ces comparaisons-là entre France et États-Unis et cette position un petit peu retranchée, un petit peu défensive que moi j'ai perçue.
Je ne sais pas si c'est pareil pour toi ?
Oui, oui, oui, pour moi, 'fin, c'est quelque chose d'assez commun en France, d'assez récurrent. Les gens opposent une très très forte résistance à l'idée que l'on puisse comparer la France aux États-Unis.
Alors, déjà, faut qu'on s'entende sur ce que signifie comparer. Comparer, ça ne veut pas dire expliquer que deux choses sont similaires.
On peut comparer des choses qui ne sont pas exactement les mêmes. Donc déjà, y a ça qui me semble étonnant.
L'autre chose, c'est que les États-Unis sont une ancienne colonie qui a été fondée par des Européens. Et donc les Européens ont exporté aux États-Unis des idéologies qui sont nées sur notre sol.
Donc on ne peut pas dire que la France n'a absolument rien à voir avec l'idéologie raciale qui est venue coloniser les États-Unis.
La France a participé au commerce triangulaire des esclaves et la France surtout est en Amérique. C'est-à-dire que la France, elle est présente sur le sol américain.
Dans ses départements, on a des départements dans les Caraïbes et le seul territoire de l'Amérique du Sud qui soit encore sous contrôle européen, c'est la Guyane française.
Donc on ne peut pas dire qu'on n'a rien à voir avec le racisme de l'Amérique. De l'Amérique en tant que continent, parce que notre présence montre qu'on a eu cette,
cette, par le passé, cette allant coloniale et qu'on a pratiqué l'esclavage qui a structuré les rapports sociaux aux États-Unis.
Alors la différence, c'est que l'esclavage, le racisme, le génocide aussi des populations natives sont consubstantiels de l'identité américaine.
C'est-à-dire que les États-Unis ont existé dans cette construction raciale. La France existait avant le commerce triangulaire et avant la colonisation.
Toutefois, la République a été coloniale. La République a justifié la colonisation de populations asiatiques, africaines.
Et voilà. Donc dire qu'on n'a rien à voir, c'est... moi, je trouve que c'est un peu une fantaisie.
Alors bien sûr, nous sommes différents, nous avons notre propre histoire du racisme, et là-dessus, je pense que c'est important de ne pas plaquer 'fin l'imagerie américaine sur la nôtre.
Mais on peut pas faire comme si nous n'avions pas parmi nos ressortissants des gens qui descendaient de cette histoire d'esclavage.
Je veux dire, les personnes qui sont antillaises, guyanaises, qui sont de La Réunion, elles viennent de cette histoire de l'esclavage.
Elles ont été importées massivement. Donc le fait qu'on ait parmi nos citoyens des gens qui descendent de cette histoire-là
montre qu'on a quand même quelque chose à voir avec cette histoire globale du capitalisme et de l'esclavage.
Donc non, en France, oui, structurellement, le territoire français a été constitué tel qu'il est aujourd'hui. Le territoire français, il a été structurellement constitué par le racisme, par l'esclavage et par la colonisation.
Le fait que nous ayons des départements ultramarins est le fruit d'un racisme d'État. D'un racisme d'État qui produit encore des conséquences puisque les citoyens et citoyennes d'outre-mer sont structurellement discriminés.
Y avait une manifestation la semaine dernière contre les discriminations raciales postcoloniales que subissent ces départements pourtant français.
Et je pense qu'on ne peut pas le nier et que la pensée qui refuse l'analogie, c'est une pensée qui, d'une certaine manière, ne tient pas compte de ces citoyens-là.
Tu m'offres une magnifique transition pour qu'on puisse reposer un petit peu les bases, reprendre le racisme à ses racines.
Le racisme et les races sont des constructions sociales. Ça n'a pas toujours existé. Auparavant, voilà, à l'époque de la Grèce antique, de Marco Polo, etc., cette idée de découpage racial, ça n'existait pas.
Et puis petit à petit, notamment, et donc tu évoquais l'histoire des États-Unis, voilà, construite en grande partie par des esclaves, 'fin des esclaves africains.
À ce moment-là, y a une construction, on commence à avoir des catégories sociales entre les Nègres, les Blancs.
Y a... ce qu'on peut dire qu'il y a,
un jeu de construction théologico-politico-culturel, puisque même dans la Bible,
on détourne certaines formulations pour dire que la malédiction de Cham, le fils de Noé, dont la descendance est maudite, eh bien en fait, maintenant,
on perçoit qu'il s'agirait des personnes noires.
Bon, y a un détournement du texte d'origine, évidemment. Et puis voilà, petit à petit, la roue tourne.
On commence à faire des constructions au niveau de la science pour soutenir cette idée de race à un niveau biologique, cette quête, cette hiérarchisation
de ces catégorisations, voilà, construites, arbitraires, pour que finalement, les individus soient enfermés de manière irrécupérable dans ces cases.
Et on ne peut pas, voilà, on ne peut pas s'échapper de sa condition de racisé. Je fais un fast forward à l'époque actuelle.
Je crois que c'était l'an dernier, corrige-moi si je me trompe, mais la France a décidé de supprimer le mot « race » de la Constitution.
Est-ce que tu estimes que c'était une bonne compensation ou bien est-ce que c'était maladroit de la part de la France de faire ça ?
Alors, cette décision, pour l'instant, elle a été adoptée par l'Assemblée nationale, mais pas encore par le Sénat. Mais elle a été adoptée à l'unanimité par l'Assemblée nationale.
OK. OK. Donc c'est bien parti quoi.
Ouais, oui, oui. C'est... donc de supprimer le mot « race » de la Constitution.
Alors, ce qui est étonnant, c'est qu'elle veut le supprimer alors que dans la Constitution, il était présent pour dire que les citoyens étaient traités sans distinction de race.
Et ce qui est intéressant aussi, c'est que le mot serait remplacé par « sexe
». À une époque où on parle plus de genre que de sexe, puisque le sexe naturalise là où le genre fait écho à une construction sociale, c'est comme si en fait, on était à contretemps.
Évidemment, je ne crois pas dans les races biologiques, mais je crois que la société construit des races. Et c'est une construction qui est liée à l'histoire, comme tu l'as dit.
Dans l'Antiquité, y avait d'un côté les Barbares et de l'autre les Romains ou les Grecs. Mais on ne-
C'était une autre construction, oui, mais pas au niveau de la couleur de peau, ouais
...que la couleur de peau était constitutive d'une essence. C'est devenu le cas à un moment, en fait, où il a fallu justifier l'esclavage.
C'est-à-dire que le fait qu'on déporte massivement des Africains qui avaient tous la peau plus ou moins noire d'ailleurs, qui ne se ressemblaient pas forcément nécessairement, eh bien, on a dû inventer d'abord une mythologie religieuse en
en réinterprétant la malédiction de Cham.
Et puis, à partir du XIXe siècle, à partir... 'fin, se forger des théories pseudo-scientifiques sur les inégalités raciales comme
Joseph Arthur de... 'fin le comte de Gobineau, français qui a,
qui a forgé cet essai sur les iné... fameux, malheureusement, sur les inégalités raciales, mais qui avait d'abord été précédé par Emmanuel Kant et par d'autres intellectuels.
Donc le racisme, déjà, c'est une conception intellectuelle qui vient de personnes cultivées. C'est pas une ignorance, c'est vraiment quelque chose-
Mhm
...qui est de la pensée. C'est... le racisme, c'est une pensée, c'est une construction.
Donc, si on part de ça et qu'on dit que les races aujourd'hui, tout le monde reconnaît qu'il n'y a plus, la plupart des gens en tout cas, qu'il n'y a pas d'inégalités biologiques,
malgré tout, dans la manière dont les rapports sociaux sont structurés, les gens, en fonction de leur couleur de peau, de leurs origines, sont traités différemment.
Eh bien, à partir de là, on est obligé de dire que oui, malheureusement, socialement, les races existent puisque les gens sont discriminés.
Donc si on enlève dans la Constitution le fait que les gens ne peuvent pas être traités différemment en fonction de leur race, alors la race, c'est ce qui leur est attribué socialement,
on n'a plus de fondement en fait pour lutter contre le racisme.
Et je trouve qu'il y a cette idée dans la suppression de ce mot, que d'un coup de baguette magique, on pourrait faire disparaître-
Mhm
...un mot, un mal, et des maux, M-A-U-X,
Ouais
...simplement en supprimant un mot, M-O-T. Et je trouve que c'est ridicule en fait. Ça ne marche pas comme ça. Il faut lutter contre le racisme.
Il faut pas lutter contre les mots, il faut lutter contre l'idéologie et ses conséquences sociétales.
Donc toi, tu l'aurais gardé dans la Constitution si tu avais été présidente de l'Assemblée nationale et que tu avais pu, d'un coup de bag... 'fin, influer sur cette décision ?
Tu penses que garder cette... ben parce que voilà, en fait, ce qu'il y a, c'est que, voilà, je pose cette question un petit peu du point de vue des auditeurs et des auditrices.
Y a à la fois dans ce que tu dis une dénonciation du fait que c'est construit, que c'est, que ça n'a aucune base scientifique factuelle, et que donc c'est quelque chose qu'on a envie
on a envie d'effacer un petit peu ces considérations raciales arbitraires et, comme tu dis, voilà, construites de toutes pièces.
Et en même temps, on a l'impression que tu dis : « Ben en fait, c'est pas une bonne idée de faire disparaître ce mot ».
Mais parce que c'est important de parler de race pour la dépasser. C'est-à-dire que si on n'en parle pas, on ne peut pas trouver d'outils pour lutter.
Et je pense que ce terme-là est un outil, c'est-à-dire qu'on reconnaît socialement les conséquences d'inégalités racistes et qui construisent une notion de race.
Et si on ne le fait pas, qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? C'est-à-dire que 'fin, moi, je trouve ça aussi très étonnant, par exemple, de vouloir introduire le mot « sexe » dans la Constitution à une époque où on sait que le sexe-
Ouais, je trouve aussi
...c'est fluctuant quoi, c'est quelque chose de-
Tout à fait, ouais.
'Fin je veux dire, là, c'est remettre de l'essence biologique là où il n'y a plus lieu d'être. C'est-à-dire qu'on pourrait parler de genre.
Ça aurait été une évolution, parce que le genre, on sait que c'est une construction sociale, qu'il y a des gens qui sont intersexes, des gens qui sont transgenres.
Donc du coup, la question du sexe, c'est une question qui est passée pour moi, 'fin qui est vraiment... Et du coup, c'est comme si on,
on reculait sur quelque chose sur lequel on a fait énormément de progrès et qu'on évacue une question qu'on ne voulait plus voir.
À la base, dans la Constitution, ce terme était vraiment là pour dire qu'on ne traite pas les gens de manière distincte en fonction de leur race.
Alors peut-être qu'on aurait pu ajouter une précision pour dire que c'est une race non pas biologique, mais sociale, mais je trouve que ça n'a aucun sens.
Mhm.
Ce qui aurait du sens-
C'est ça.
...pour les législateurs, c'est vraiment de mettre en place un plan d'action national contre le racisme, ce qui n'est pas le cas.
C'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui, il n'y a pas de politique véritablement antiraciste qui permette d'abattre des barrières et qui permette aussi aux gens qui agissent de manière raciste de ne pas avoir un sentiment d'impunité.
Parce qu'aujourd'hui, en réalité, quand on discrimine, les sanctions sont très rares. Et ça, c'est un vrai problème.
Et donc quand tu évoques l'idée de la nécessité de mentionner les races pour lutter contre le racisme, là, on est très très très très loin de l'idéal universaliste républicain.
Et donc j'ai l'impression que dans cette idée de supprimer le mot « race » de la Constitution, c'est un petit peu cacher ses seins que je ne saurais voir.
C'est on met ses mains sur ses yeux et on fait semblant de ne rien voir. Et on fait, voilà, comme tu dis, on fait un coup de baguette magique pour essayer de faire disparaître-
Oui.
...ces discussions-là. Alors qu'effectivement, comme on le disait, aux États-Unis, ça se passe très différemment puisqu'on a reconnu,
je crois que c'était un arrêt de la Cour suprême, je ne sais plus, mais on a reconnu les Africains-Américains comme un groupe, non pas pour leur couleur ou pour leur race biologique, mais
pour leur histoire commune quoi.
Donc pour la race au sens construction sociale, le fait qu'ils avaient une histoire commune, tirée de, voilà, l'esclavage et tout ce qu'on connaît.
Je voulais me placer l'espace d'un instant à la place des auditeurs et auditrices qui,
voilà, qui ont grandi en francophonie, qui sont le produit de leur environnement et qui donc portent en eux et en elles, voilà, à une plus ou moins grande échelle, du racisme en eux, en elles.
Si diviser
la population française, belge ou autre en plusieurs catégories,
leur assigner des clichés pour un petit peu structurer le monde qui nous entoure, un petit peu essayer de mieux le saisir, de simplifier les choses pour avoir une meilleure compréhension
des gens qui nous entourent, de notre société.
Et au finalement, voilà, le racisme, c'est aussi quand on est blanc, s'imaginer au sommet de cette hiérarchie. Si tout ça, c'est si confortable,
et c'est peut-être une question un peu violente que je vais poser, mais à quoi ça leur servirait de s'émanciper de tout ça ?
Est-ce que c'est pas beaucoup plus confortable de faire semblant, comme par exemple l'Assemblée nationale française, de faire semblant qu'y a pas de souci ?
Bah bien sûr, en fait, l'intérêt pour les personnes qui sont en situation de domination, pardon, c'est de maintenir un statu quo.
Si vous vivez dans une société où les personnes non blanches sont structurellement discriminées et que vous êtes blanc ou blanche, ça veut dire que pour vous, c'est plus facile, mais parce que d'autres sont discriminés.
Donc si quelqu'un se voit refuser un appartement, peut-être que vous l'aurez, quelles que soient vos convictions. Donc ça veut dire qu'y a plein de bénéfices dont vous n'avez pas conscience, mais qui vous rendent la vie en réalité plus facile.
Donc évidemment, si tout d'un coup, on vous oblige à faire face à tout ça, ça vous oblige à questionner votre position par rapport à d'autres.
Évidemment, ça vous oblige à penser,
à vos privilèges et ça peut être très difficile. Donc c'est vrai que pour des personnes, par exemple, qui sont très moyennes dans la vie politique, qui ne sont pas des personnes,
comment dire, au talent exceptionnel, hein, je pense aux hommes qui sont surreprésentés et aux personnes blanches.
Si tout d'un coup, on rétablissait l'égalité, eh bien peut-être que ce serait plus compliqué pour ces personnes-là d'accéder aux postes qu'elles ont aujourd'hui, en réalité.
Donc c'est sûr que pour quelqu'un qui est moyen, qui appartient à une génération où il fallait être un homme
d'un certain âge pour accéder au pouvoir, etc., bah peut-être que cette personne-là se dit que, enfin, elle se le dit pas forcément consciemment, hein, parce qu'on se raconte toujours ce mythe de la méritocratie.
Mais en réalité, oui, c'est pas dans leur intérêt. C'est-à-dire si tout d'un coup l'Assemblée nationale devient paritaire, bah ça veut dire que tout d'un coup y aura des hommes en moins.
Donc évidemment, ça leur fait pas plaisir.
Je pose cette question parce que voilà, on avait reçu dans ce podcast, il y a à peu près un an, donc Olivia Gazalé qui a publié un livre : « Le mythe de la virilité », donc sur les questions de genre cette fois-ci.
Son message, c'était de dire finalement : ces constructions résultent en une oppression sur les femmes, mais aussi une prison
pour les hommes qui sont moins libres, voilà, que ce soit en termes d'exprimer leurs émotions, en termes de, voilà, tous les rôles genrés, finalement.
Et donc, ce qui avait été très frappant, c'est que suite à la publication de cet épisode, j'ai reçu
un paquet de retours d'auditeurs et de, oui, d'auditeurs, pas d'auditrices, mais des auditeurs qui, voilà, exprimaient
presque une forme de soulagement de se dire : « Ah, j'y avais jamais pensé ».
Et voilà, et on sentait qu'ils commençaient à se libérer d'un poids, le poids de ces rôles genrés.
Mais là, je cherche un petit peu le parallèle quand on parle du racisme, quand on parle des races, en particulier donc la blanchité.
Quel est le bienfait pour les Blancs qui nous écoutent de remettre tout ça en question ?
Alors, bon déjà, je pense qu'on ne peut pas faire un parallèle total parce que la construction des genres repose aussi sur des rôles sociaux très explicites, sur des rôles sociaux-
Ouais.
...qui sont beaucoup plus clairement explicites dans la question de la virilité performative chez les hommes, le fait de se placer comme protecteur,
le fait d'effectuer des tâches domestiques pour les femmes, d'avoir une forme de douceur, dans la tenue, hein.
Les tenues sont marquées aussi par les rôles sociaux de genre. Pour les questions raciales, c'est beaucoup moins lisible.
C'est-à-dire qu'y a pas, de manière très très claire, une posture de Blanc et une posture de non-Blanc. C'est pas aussi clair.
D'ailleurs, c'est très culturel tout ça, la manière dont on s'exprime, la position qu'on prend.
Après, comme le disait Lilian Thuram l'année dernière, ce qui lui a valu une polémique assez incroyable, il disait que oui, quand on est blanc, on est élevé avec un complexe de supériorité.
Parce que tout nous dit qu'on est la norme. De la télévision aux magazines, tout nous explique en fait qu'on est la personne par défaut et on n'est jamais nommé en tant que Blanc.
C'est-à-dire que toutes les personnes qui sont nommées sont les minorités, les Noirs, les musulmans, les Asiatiques. Même si y a des musulmans blancs hein, mais quand on dit les musulmans, en général, on ne pense pas à ceux qui sont blancs.
Donc ce sont toujours les minorités que l'on nomme. Mais les Blancs, en fait, sont considérés comme la norme implicite.
Et donc le fait de ne jamais être nommé, d'être considéré comme le référent de tous et en plus blanc, on voit bien que dans l'imaginaire, je veux dire les gens qui sont blancs, en vérité, n'ont pas la peau vraiment blanche. Sauf que blanc-
Beige, ouais.
...c'est la pureté, c'est la grandeur, etc., etc. Alors que les personnes noires n'ont pas la peau noire, mais des dégradés de marron,
eh bien noir, c'est l'obscurité, c'est quelque chose de très très négatif.
Donc quand on est élevé dans un monde qui nous a constitué comme à la fois la norme, comme le bien,
comme le référent absolu de l'humanité, parce que voilà, on définit tous les autres à partir des Blancs, les cheveux, on les qualifie de crépus pour les autres, les yeux, on les qualifie de bridés pour les Asiatiques, alors que,
voilà, la bride, c'est comme le dit ma comparse Grace Ly qui présente « Tu fais race » avec moi, notre podcast. Eh bien,
bridé, ça veut dire qu'ils sont restreints, alors que c'est pas le cas.
Donc y a toujours cette idée que cette minorité dans l'humanité, parce qu'en réalité, les Blancs, j'pense qu'à l'échelle de l'humanité sont une minorité, ils ont réussi à se constituer comme norme.
Donc évidemment, quand on grandit comme Blanc et que le monde entier nous explique qu'on est la norme absolue de l'humanité entière, on développe un complexe de supériorité par rapport aux autres.
Et on n'arrive pas à se qualifier, c'est-à-dire qu'on se qualifie pas. On voit des différences entre les personnes blanches qu'on qualifie individuellement.
En revanche, une personne noire va être, pardon, assimilée, son comportement va être assimilé à celui d'un groupe.
Moi, je ne sais pas combien de fois on m'a expliqué que, bah dans mes détracteurs hein, que j'avais la prétention de représenter les Noirs, que je les représentais pas bien,
mais je n'ai jamais dit que je représentais qui que ce soit.
Je ne suis pas élue, mais parce que je suis noire, on imagine que je représente
les Noirs. Il se trouve que je suis une femme noire, donc quand on me voit, en fait, on n'arrive pas à s'empêcher de m'associer à l'ensemble d'un groupe supposé.
Quand Alain Finkielkraut, quand Eric Zemmour, quand Marine Le Pen s'expriment, on ne pense pas qu'ils parlent au nom des Blancs.
Pourtant, ce qu'ils défendent dans leurs propos, c'est la préséance de l'identité blanche. C'est très explicite dans leur idéologie.
Donc on voit bien que dans les personnes minoritaires, on réduit en fait les propos des personnes minoritaires à des propos qui seraient les propos d'un groupe, qui seraient les propos d'un groupe monolithique. Et c'est encore-
Et ça, est-ce que ça, c'est vrai uniquement quand on s'exprime, je dirais, dans les médias, en public ou bien est-ce que--
parce que voilà, y a un petit peu, et c'est quelque chose que j'ai également eu l'occasion de remarquer, c'est cette espèce de « vous » un peu flou.
On dit : « Oui, mais vous, vous pensez quoi ? Et vous, qu'est-ce que vous dites ? » Et ce « vous », en fait, signifie en vrai : « Vous, les Noirs ».
Parce qu'on présume que
voilà, tu es là pour représenter, vous, les Noirs. Est-ce que ça, c'est quelque chose qui est avéré dans les médias ou bien est-ce que c'est en fait omniprésent dans ta vie de tous les jours ?
En fait,
c'est ça le racisme en fait. C'est que le racisme invisibilise les individus. C'est-à-dire qu'il considère que les groupes minoritaires forment des blocs monolithiques et que leur individualité n'a pas d'incidence
sur leur personnalité, que leur personnalité est mue par des caractéristiques qui sont partagées par l'ensemble d'un groupe.
Et on le voit par exemple dans le traitement de l'actualité sur les terroristes. Quand un terroriste est blanc, je pense à Anders Breivik.
Déjà, il est difficilement qualifié de terroriste. Et moi, je me souviens de papiers dans la presse française qui disaient : « Dans la tête du tueur aux yeux bleus ». Voilà-
C'est un peu, ouais, un peu romantique, un petit peu poétique, ouais, c'est ça.
On humanise. On parle d'un homme qui a les yeux bleus. Moi, j'ai lu aussi, par exemple-- donc Anders Breivik, c'est le terroriste norvégien qui avait tué, une à une, 77, 78 personnes il y a quelques années.
Je pense également à Dylann Roof, qui est cet homme qui était rentré dans une église noire, qui avait assisté aux États-Unis, à Charleston, en Caroline du Sud, me semble-t-il,
qui avait assisté à une messe et qui après cela avait tué de sang-froid neuf personnes noires.
Donc qui était un terroriste qui n'a pas été présenté comme tel, qui, quand il a été arrêté, s'est vu remettre un gilet pare-balles par la police.
Donc tout d'un coup, sa vie comptait alors que des personnes noires innocentes étaient tuées sans égard par la police.
Et on lui a même offert un stop chez Burger King pendant le trajet qu'il menait vers la police. Donc vraiment, ses besoins d'être humain ont été considérés.
Cet homme-là, je me souviens avoir lu dans un média, il me semble suisse, qu'il avait été quitté par sa petite amie quelque temps auparavant.
C'est-à-dire que quand des terroristes sont blancs, on arrive à trouver des circonstances psychologiques individuelles qui permettent d'expliquer leur passage à l'acte.
Quand les terroristes sont non blancs et ou musulmans, eh bien tout à coup, c'est l'ensemble de la communauté musulmane qu'on interroge.
De la communauté construite, évidemment, parce que je pense pas qu'il y ait une communauté musulmane, mais c'est l'ensemble des musulmans qui sont sommés
de se désolidariser, pardon, qui sont questionnés, qui sont accusés.
Tant qu'ils n'ont rien dit, on estime qu'ils sont solidaires. Et on ne demande jamais, je veux dire, les gens du Ku Klux Klan,
certains commandos anti-IVG, sont des suprémacistes blancs, des gens qui invoquent le christianisme.
On ne demande pas à l'ensemble des chrétiens, à l'ensemble des Blancs de se désolidariser ou d'indiquer qu'ils ne sont pas par défaut des gens qui soutiennent ce genre d'idéologie.
Donc c'est ça le racisme. Quand on demande à quelqu'un d'individuel ce que vous pensez, vous les Noirs, vous les Arabes, vous les Asiatiques, eh bien on lui nie son humanité,
on le déshumanise, on considère que son individualité n'a pas plus de force que son appartenance à un groupe.
Et ça, ça se passe aussi bien au niveau médiatique qu'au niveau interindividuel.
Ce que tu expliques également dans ton livre donc, « Racisme : mode d'emploi », c'est que
toi, tu ne veux pas juger le racisme sur un plan moral et que tu veux qu'il soit jugé avant tout sur un plan, beh, rationnel, factuel et juridique aussi, puisque le racisme est un délit, en tout cas en France.
Je repense à une vidéo que tu as publiée sur Instagram, je crois que c'était cet été, où tu te promenais à Paris et où tu as eu une interaction assez désagréable avec une personne qui était assise en terrasse.
Voilà, une personne qui a tenu des propos racistes que j'ai pas forcément envie de répéter aujourd'hui. Je me souviens que dans cette vidéo, voilà, on te sentait très énervée, très agacée.
Et donc là, est-ce que ce jour-là, tu ne jugeais pas cette personne sur un plan moral, une faute morale ?
Alors moi, ce que je dis, c'est que le racisme ne se juge pas sur le plan moral, mais factuel. C'est-à-dire qu'il s'agit pas de dire que telle personne est gentille, telle personne est méchante, telle personne mérite notre compréhension ou non.
Il s'agit de juger les propos et leur incidence. C'est-à-dire que moi, je n'ai que faire de savoir si telle personne qui a proféré des propos racistes est sympathique, est gentille, a un époux noir, a adopté des enfants du Vietnam ou que sais-je.
Ce qui compte pour moi, c'est le propos. Et les juger tels quels. Donc pas chercher à juger sur le plan moral.
Là, la personne dont tu parles, c'est une personne qui m'a insultée dans la rue. Donc déjà, l'injure, c'est public, c'est un délit.
Et après, je suis un être humain. C'est-à-dire que moi, quand on m'insulte, je réagis, je suis énervée. C'est pas un jugement moral, c'est juste que moi, j'ai été agressée, en fait.
Et pour moi, c'est pas moral. C'est quelqu'un qui m'a agressée alors que j'étais tranquillement assise à une terrasse et que je ne le connaissais pas.
Donc pour moi, je veux dire cette personne-là, j'en ai rien à faire. Si ça se trouve, dans sa vie quotidienne, si ça se trouve, cette personne est formidable.
Mais à ce moment-là,
c'est une personne qui m'a agressée de manière complètement gratuite dans des termes injurieux. Et donc c'est-- alors là, je sais pas,
justement, la question morale, parce que sa petite amie l'a défendu en disant : « Mais non, nanana », etc.
Quelle que soit la personne et quoi qu'on me dise sur cette personne-là, ça ne m'intéressera pas. Moi, ce qui m'intéresse, c'est de savoir qu'à cet instant T, cette personne m'a agressée sans aucune raison.
Ouais, mais donc tu parles alors d'une faute éthique ? Parce que c'est ça que j'ai du mal à-
En France, en fait, les injures, je veux dire, c'est illégal, en fait, on n'a pas le droit d'en faire.
OK. Mais donc c'est-à-dire que si c'était pas dans la loi, tu ne te serais pas énervée ? Tu n'aurais pas jugé ça comme étant quelque chose de-
La loi est suffisamment bien faite pour que l'intégrité des gens soit respectée. Donc à partir du moment où on s'en prend à mon intégrité physique, pour moi, on est dans le
manque de respect à la fois de la loi française, mais aussi de tous les textes qui protègent les droits humains.
Donc je pense que c'est-- après, y a des choses qui sont très claires. Quand on s'en prend à l'intégrité morale ou physique d'une personne, pour moi, c'est très clair.
C'est-à-dire qu'on n'est plus dans le théorique, c'est pas un débat où quelqu'un parle comme ça sans parler de quelqu'un.
Quand on vise verbalement une personne, c'est pas de l'éthique. Là, c'est vraiment, on agresse quelqu'un.
Et c'est pour moi, c'est pas de l'éthique.
OK, OK, c'est intéressant.
Un débat de philo à faire peut-être dans un prochain épisode. Mais pour poursuivre sur cette question,
je repense à nouveau aux auditeurs, aux auditrices qui nous écoutent aujourd'hui et qui, peut-être, en nous écoutant,
voilà, prennent conscience de ce racisme, ce que tu appelles dans le livre un racisme atmosphérique, quoi, un racisme ambiant
auquel personne n'échappe vraiment.
On n'est jamais complètement déconstruit. Les auditeurs qui prennent conscience de leur racisme en nous écoutant, peut-être qu'ils ressentent une forme de...
Je posais la question autrement. Qu'est-ce que tu aimerais voir ces auditeurs ressentir ? Est-ce qu'une forme de culpabilité et de honte ?
Et là, on est peut-être alors un peu plus sur le plan moral, sachant que la honte, c'est quelque chose de très présent dans nos cultures, voilà, ici en Europe.
Ou bien est-ce que, au contraire, tu aimerais voir
une approche beaucoup plus méthodique, factuelle, s'assumer en toute transparence, reconnaître : « Ah oui, effectivement, j'ai été construit dans cette société occidentale, avec ce racisme ambiant, ce racisme atmosphérique.
Et donc je n'ai pas échappé. » Et donc voilà, finalement assumer cette part raciste que voilà, qu'on comporte tous et toutes ici.
La culpabilité, ça sert à rien. C'est-à-dire la culpabilité, la contrition individuelle, ça n'a aucun sens.
Et moi, je n'attends pas des-
D'autant plus qu'elle freine sans doute un petit peu la déconstruction, elle freine sans doute les avancées, puisque généralement, quand on ressent une honte et une culpabilité, on a
surtout envie de faire semblant de rien du tout.
C'est ça. En fait, moi, ce que je pense, c'est qu'il faut reconnaître que chacun et chacune, on vit dans un climat, dans une atmosphère qui est consubstantiellement raciste et que du coup, on est imprégné de tout ça.
C'est comme le sexisme, en fait, c'est quelque chose qui structure nos sociétés et donc on est imprégné de ça au quotidien dans toutes les interactions qu'on a, dans les médias, dans les livres, etc., etc.
Et que du coup, on peut reproduire en tant qu'individu des choses qu'on a apprises. Parce qu'en fait, le racisme, c'est aussi un apprentissage, c'est pas quelque chose d'inné.
Donc à partir de là, quand on le fait, il faut reconnaître qu'on l'a fait. C'est-à-dire que ça veut pas dire, ça fait pas de nous une mauvaise personne.
C'est en ça que je vais pas rentrer dans la morale, c'est que ça veut pas dire qu'on est une mauvaise personne. Ça veut simplement dire qu'on a, à un moment donné, commis une erreur.
Et reconnaître cette erreur, c'est avancer. Ça ne veut pas dire : « Oh mon Dieu, je suis quelqu'un de méchant, je reconnais, je me sens coupable, je me sens pas bien.
» Non, j'ai commis une erreur, je suis désolée. On peut présenter des excuses auprès des personnes
qu'on a offensées. On peut essayer de réparer les dommages puisque c'est une notion qui existe aussi en droit et avancer et ne pas reproduire en fait ces erreurs.
Et pour moi, c'est ça en fait. C'est-à-dire que tous autant qu'on est, on a intériorisé un certain nombre de préjugés qui peuvent nous amener à agir
d'une telle ou telle manière ou à dire des choses qui sont racistes, qui sont sexistes, qui sont homophobes.
Assumer son erreur, et donc erreur sur le plan, de nouveau, factuel, rationnel, le renvoyer au fait que
toutes ces choses-là sont construites, arbitraires, que ça prend racine dans, voilà, la colonialité, finalement, le colonialisme d'il y a quelques siècles déjà.
Et donc voilà, renvoyer au non-sens de la démarche raciste dont on parle alors.
Est-ce que tu apprécies alors quand tu as une discussion avec,
on va plutôt parler des personnes blanches qui généralement ont très peu conscience, comme on disait tout à l'heure, de leur couleur de peau et de leur race.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que tu apprécies quand, ce racisme atmosphérique, ambiant, dont on a beaucoup de mal à s'extraire.
Est-ce que tu apprécies quand c'est finalement presque assumé, reconnu de dire : « Ah ouais, j'avoue, moi, je pense ça, j'ai ce cliché-là sur les Noirs, j'ai ce cliché-là sur les Arabes ».
Ou bien est-ce que ça te met profondément mal à l'aise quand il y a cette espèce de transparence ?
Quand il y a une transparence sans forcément un regret et une forme de honte qui accompagne le truc.
Moi, ça m'intéresse pas particulièrement en fait de discuter de ça en dehors de mon travail. C'est-à-dire que-
Ouais
...puis quand c'est mon travail, quand c'est un débat où je suis sous contrat, où j'écris, etc., je réfléchis, c'est intéressant.
En fait quand t'es payée pour économiser, d'accord.
Bah oui, parce que c'est pas forcément-- j'veux dire dans ma vie quotidienne, j'fais autre chose en fait.
Bien sûr.
Donc moi, c'est vrai que-- bon, c'est pas des conversations que j'ai forcément tout le temps avec les personnes blanches de mon entourage.
Après, je peux leur raconter des choses qui sont survenues dans le cadre de mon travail, mais c'est vrai que moi, j'ai pas envie de faire l'éducation de gens ou de guider
forcément des gens dans leur prise de conscience du racisme, parce que ça, c'est un boulot en fait.
Alors oui, je pense qu'on-- ouais, je me suis peut-être mal exprimé dans ma question, mais donc-
Non, bah voilà. Quand même, même si c'est pas la question que t'as posée exactement,
je pense que c'est important pour les personnes blanches de ne pas aller voir les personnes minoritaires pour comprendre leur propre racisme s'ils pensent qu'ils ont du racis-- parce que la personne minoritaire subit déjà du racisme au quotidien.
On peut pas lui donner en plus la charge d'éduquer des gens qui ne sont pas éduqués sachant qu'on est en 2020, qu'y a Internet, qu'on a accès à énormément de livres dans plein de langues, des contenus vidéo, etc.,
qui peuvent nous faire notre éducation.
Donc je pense que le minimum, c'est de prendre en charge sa propre éducation et de justement permettre aux gens qui vivent le racisme de ne pas être éprouvé davantage.
Après, c'est vrai que moi, j'apprécie que les gens reconnaissent. C'est-à-dire que moi, je sais que dans mon éducation, je suis capable de dire des choses problématiques pour des gens qui ne sont pas de mon groupe.
C'est-à-dire que des-- 'fin, j'ai pu dire par le passé des choses transphobes. Bah il a fallu qu'une personne transgenre me le signale pour que j'arrête de dire ces choses-là.
Et heureusement. C'est-à-dire que je pense qu'il faut avoir un peu d'humilité et se dire que bah déjà, cette personne a été suffisamment généreuse pour prendre son temps et venir me dire que ce que tu as dit est problématique.
Le minimum, c'est de respecter ça et de se remettre en question. Et ça, je trouve que c'est important. Donc reconnaître ce qu'on peut dire de problématique à l'égard de groupes qui ne sont pas nous, je trouve que c'est une bonne chose, oui.
Tu fais très bien de le préciser. Et donc,
tu dis : « Approcher une personne racisée avec ces questions-là, avec ces interrogations, ces doutes, ces remises en question et chercher finalement une forme de coaching »,
c'est sans doute plutôt maladroit puisque la personne n'a sans doute pas envie de penser à ça.
Et, 'fin, bon, c'est peut-être une question très précise et un peu étrange, mais le fait de mentionner la dimension raciale de,
voilà, de nos existences, de nos sociétés, sans forcément en faire une session, voilà, une,
une-- sans avoir des exigences pédagogiques, mais le fait de mentionner ça dans une conversation, j'ai parfois l'impression qu'en France, c'est : « Ouh là non, surtout pas parler de ça.
Non, sujet absolument-
C'est interdit
...sujet absolument touchy ».
C'est interdit.
et est-ce que--
alors du coup, voilà, donc si on pose le contexte et qu'on dit : « En France, c'est interdit »
et que je reviens vers toi, l'individu, et que je ne t'essentialise pas à ta nature française, la-- est-ce que toi, c'est un sujet qui,
oui, ça peut apparaître dans une conversation comme un, comme, voilà, on remet les choses en contexte, on parle de race, c'est normal et pas de souci ?
Bien sûr, j'en parle. Parce que déjà, bah on peut pas être une femme noire en France sans jamais évoquer les conséquences que ça a dans le quotidien.
Donc les regards de travers, le fait d'être mal servie dans tel ou tel type d'établissement. J'veux dire, bien sûr, passer une frontière, c'est-- tout est un sujet.
Et évidemment, les remarques qu'on peut nous faire au travail, les gens qui essayent de nous toucher les cheveux, c'est des choses, on peut pas ne pas en parler.
Bien-- donc c'est un sujet. Mais c'est un sujet avec lequel les gens qui sont concernés, donc qui vivent le racisme, sont beaucoup plus à l'aise que les autres.
Les autres, en fait, qui sont pas concernés, alors y en a qui sont sensibilisés et avec lesquels ça se passe très bien, mais d'autres vont beaucoup passer de temps à remettre en question.
« Est-ce que tu es sûr qu'on t'a pas laissé entrer parce que tu n'avais-- tu avais des baskets ? » « Mais ah bon, mais moi, je touche tes cheveux parce que c'est de la curiosité, c'est pas parce que t'es noire ».
'Fin, et ça, c'est de l'énergie qu'on n'a pas forcément envie de dépenser. C'est-à-dire qu'on n'a pas envie d'être dans un rapport où, comme le dit Marie Da Silva, qui est coach en stratégie
pour les femmes qui sont victimes de discrimination, elle dit qu'on ne doit pas justifier son humanité auprès de personnes qui la questionnent.
Et c'est ça. C'est que oui, effectivement, on n'a pas forcément l'énergie de vouloir parler de questions raciales avec des gens qui nient l'existence du racisme alors que nous, on le vit dans notre chair depuis notre naissance quoi.
On a généralement l'impression en France que dire à une personne noire qu'elle est noire, c'est absolument interdit et c'est complètement incompatible avec, de nouveau, l'universalisme français.
Mais toi, tu nous dis qu'en fait, bah ça ne pose aucun souci et qu'on peut parler de race, on peut parler de-
C'est plus dur de dire à une personne blanche qu'elle est blanche. C'est-à-dire que j'ai l'impression que c'est plus difficile en France, c'est de dire blanc.
Moi, je sais qu'en permanence,
on me qualifie de raciste anti-Blanc parce que je parle autant des personnes non blanches que des personnes blanches, parce que-- y a pas de raison que je n'oriente ma réflexion sur le racisme uniquement sur les personnes qui en sont victimes.
Ça n'a aucun sens. Donc les personnes blanches ont tellement peu l'habitude d'être désignées comme telles qu'elles le vivent, enfin les--
beaucoup de personnes blanches, parce que je vais pas faire de généralités, sont si peu habituées à être désignées comme étant des personnes blanches qu'elles le vivent comme une attaque et comme une violence.
Mh.
Et qu'elles ont l'impression que c'est du racisme. Et je veux dire, c'est vraiment ne pas comprendre ce qu'est le racisme que de croire qu'être qualifié de blanc, c'est une violence ou une détestation.
C'est tout simplement un constat. Et un constat qui veut justement interroger tout ce qui en découle en termes de privilèges et de perception sociale.
Donc moi, j'ai l'impression que c'est plus ça qui est difficile en France. Là où dans d'autres pays, oui, les Blancs savent qu'ils sont blancs.
Tu viens de dire il y a un instant
Je ne vais pas dire tous les Blancs, mais beaucoup de Blancs.
Je fais le parallèle avec la question des études de genre où y a le fameux hashtag « Not all men », le-- voilà, les féministes qui disent : « Bah si, en fait, c'est tous les hommes qui font partie du problème ».
Ici, on parle du racisme, ce sy-- ce-- la construction sociale qui place les Blancs en haut de la pyramide. Et toi, tu dis-- 'fin, tu préfères employer la formule beaucoup de Blancs plutôt que tous les Blancs.
Parce que je parlais de-- non, c'était précisément pour la phrase que j'utilisais, c'est-à-dire que je pense-
Ouais, ouais
...tous les Blancs ne sont pas inconscients de leur couleur de peau en France. Y a des Blancs que ça dérange pas qu'on dise les Blancs.
Exact. OK, OK. Mais donc je fais la transition. Est-ce que quand on parle de la problématique du racisme, c'est tous les Blancs ou bien est-ce que c'est beaucoup de Blancs ?
Bah le privilège blanc concerne tous les Blancs. C'est-à-dire qu'après, être privilégié, ça ne veut pas dire être privilégié sur tous les plans.
On peut être blanc et pauvre. Ce que je veux dire, c'est qu'à conditions égales, donc si on est pauvre, il vaut mieux être pauvre et blanc que pauvre et non blanc. Parce que-
Bien sûr
...parce que si on est par exemple au chômage, c'est plus facile de trouver un emploi, sortir donc du chômage en étant blanc.
C'est plus facile si on est dans la rue de trouver un logement si on n'est pas blanc. Et on voit bien que même des Blancs pauvres peuvent éprouver un complexe de supériorité à l'égard de Noirs qui sont plus riches.
On le voit par exemple dans les stades de football où des gens qui sont littéralement des millionnaires,
des gens qui sont extrêmement fortunés, sont qualifiés de-- dans un vocabulaire animalier de manière extrêmement violente et raciste par des personnes blanches qui sont beaucoup plus pauvres qu'elles.
C'est-à-dire que ce sont des gens qui sont parmi les meilleurs athlètes au monde, qui sont extrêmement riches et qui sont quand même méprisés par des Blancs plus pauvres,
moins performants, physiquement, qui ont intériorisé quand même une forme de supériorité.
Donc on voit bien que c'est pas une question uniquement sociale. Donc ce privilège-là, c'est le privilège de se penser supérieur, en dépit en fait de sa condition sociale et socio-économique.
Et je dis pas que parce qu'on est riche, on devrait se sentir supérieur, mais c'est que normalement, ça n'arrive pas.
C'est ça. Ouais, ouais, c'est ça.
On ne traite pas, voilà, j'veux dire un Blanc pauvre, on ne traite pas Bernard Arnault de singe ou que sais-je.
Donc voilà, c'est ça que je veux dire. Et effectivement, ce,
ce privilège-là
concerne toutes les pra-- toutes les personnes blanches, quelle que soit leur condition sociale, parce qu'elles ont déjà le luxe de ne pas être réduites à leur couleur de peau et de ne pas avoir à penser au racisme.
Elles peuvent ne pas y penser, elles n'y sont pas obligées, alors que les personnes minoritaires doivent y penser pour leur survie.
C'est-à-dire qu'ils ne peuvent pas avoir le luxe de s'affranchir de cette question-là parce que, malheureusement, elle leur est invisible.
Donc c'est ça. Et après, sur la question de Not All Men, ou Not All Whites, puisque j'imagine que ça doit exister-
Ouais, c'est ça
...j'trouve que c'est indécent en fait. C'est-à-dire que pour moi, ce qui importe, c'est pas de récompenser les hommes qui ont la décence de ne pas battre leurs femmes.
C'est-- voilà, c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment donné-
C'est bien résumé
...voilà, non, on peut pas concentrer notre énergie pour féliciter, dresser des couronnes de laurier aux hommes qui se comportent bien.
Non. La concentration, elle est sur les victimes, sur les victimes du patriarcat. Et du patriarcat qui effectivement structure les rapports sociaux en faveur des hommes.
Ouais, tous les hommes du coup. Dans ton livre, tu exprimes aussi que la fierté est nécessaire pour, voilà, assumer sa minorité quand on est racisé.
Et donc voilà, y a-- c'est-- ça concerne, 'fin, ça concerne pas seulement les racisés d'ailleurs, ça concerne aussi la Gay Pride, ça concerne les autistes, ça concerne donc les personnes racisées également.
Et donc pour, voilà, se détacher de tout sentiment honteux, de toute stigmatisation par rapport à, voilà, son identité minorisée,
est-ce que l'universalisme français, c'est pas fondamentalement incompatible avec cette fierté ?
Est-ce que tu croises en France beaucoup de gens qui sont fiers d'être noirs ou d'être asiatiques ou ainsi de suite ?
C'est difficile de formuler cette
fierté, de la verbaliser dans un contexte français. Parce que la fierté, c'est la réparation symbolique d'une oppression de populations qui ont été marginalisées et placées au bas de la hiérarchie sociale, esthétique, voilà, ou économique.
Et donc quand on revendique une fierté en tant que personne noire, asiatique ou arabe, c'est une manière de dire pas qu'on veut mieux que les autres, mais que tout ce qu'on est et qu'on-- tout ce dont on nous dit que ça ne vaut rien, eh bien mérite,
mérite une forme de fierté.
C'est le propos de la Pride hein, la Pride LGBTQIA qui a lieu au mois de juin tous les ans en France. Donc ça veut dire que c'est possible quand même en France de revendiquer une fierté
quand on est dans un groupe opprimé.
Mais j'pense que c'est plus délicat quand il s'agit de questions raciales, parce que ces questions sont très difficiles à formuler dans le contexte français et que s'il y avait une manifestation,
de fierté noire, j'pense que ce serait perçu comme une menace, comme menaçant.
Très bien. Alors, Rokhaya, on s'approche tout doucement de la fin de ces 70 minutes,
passées avec toi. On va quand même dire un mot, et même un peu plus que ça, au sujet de ton nouveau livre qui sort ce mois-ci, aux éditions de Marabulles, donc qui est une bande dessinée que tu as écrite et qui est dessinée par Blachette.
Oui.
Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer un petit peu la démarche qui était la tienne ? Puisqu'en lisant ça, on a l'impression que c'est finalement un genre de manuel.
Et qu'-- en lisant ça, j'avais presque l'impression que c'était adressé aux hommes, adressé aux personnes qui ont besoin qu'on leur explique des choses dont les femmes ont sans doute beaucoup plus conscience.
Alors, c'est adressé à quiconque se sent concerné d'un côté ou de l'autre. C'est-à-dire donc le livre, 'fin, la BD s'appelle : « M'explique pas la vie, mec ».
C'est sur justement l'appréhension de l'espace public et de la parole publique par les femmes. Et donc tout ce qu'on appelle le mansplaining, le manterrupting.
Donc c'est la contraction de man et explaining en anglais. Donc où les hommes expliquent à des-- ou des hommes, ouais, les hommes, 'fin, d'une manière générale, expliquent à des femmes,
ce qu'elles savent, voilà, des femmes expertes ce qu'elles savent, comme s'ils étaient
mécaniquement et automatiquement
plus experts qu'elles-mêmes ou le man-interrupting qui est cette pratique qui consiste à interrompre les femmes beaucoup plus que les hommes et qu'on peut voir dans les débats politiques ou dont je peux faire l'expérience de manière assez récurrente.
Et voilà, c'est-- oui, effectivement, à la base, ça devait être un petit manuel, un petit guide,
mais aussi pour les femmes hein, pour savoir comment sortir de situations qui sont inextricables et qui font perdre beaucoup de temps, mais aussi pour se redonner de l'énergie, se redonner de la force,
revenir aussi avec humour grâce aux dessins de Blachette sur,
sur des situations quotidiennes,
de les dépeindre avec humour et puis donner des outils pour s'en sortir par le haut.
Donc vraiment, j'pense que voilà, c'est quelque chose de très commun, de très récurrent dans les réunions,
au travail, mais aussi dans les dîners familiaux où les femmes, en fait, ont beaucoup de difficultés à prendre l'espace qui devrait être le leur.
On voit dans ton livre que tu traverses les différents environnements. Y a par moments, c'est toi-même qui est illustrée sur des plateaux de TV.
Donc on imagine que ce sont des vraies expériences que tu as connues toi-même, donc de mansplaining, de man-interrupting et ainsi de suite.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose sur lequel tu as dû progresser, apprendre à réagir à ce man-interrupting, à ce mansplaining pour, voilà, avoir une présence médiatique en France ?
Est-ce que tu as dû compenser ces difficultés qu'on peut ressentir en tant que femme dans les médias ?
Bah disons que ce que j'ai beaucoup appris, c'est, j'ai appris des choses sur ma personnalité. C'est-à-dire que j'avais pas du tout conscience du fait que j'étais aussi patiente.
Ça, vraiment, je l'ai découvert dans l'exercice. J'ai pas pris de cours particulièrement. J'ai appris, vraiment, j'ai été jetée dans le grand bain, un peu comme ça, y a une dizaine d'années.
Et puis j'ai appris en naviguant hein, je continue à apprendre hein. Je sais que je fais pas toujours les passages médiatiques que je voudrais faire tels que je les ai pensés, etc.
Mais oui, j'ai appris vraiment sur le tas. Puis j'ai compris surtout que j'avais une parole qui était une parole féminine, jeune aussi au début quand j'ai commencé et qui était,
pas forcément prise au sérieux, qui était interrompue beaucoup plus facilement que d'autres.
Et donc, c'est quelque chose avec lequel je continue à naviguer, que je, hier encore, j'ai dû faire remarquer à un homme qui m'interrompait que je l'avais écouté posément et donc je le priais de me laisser poursuivre ma réflexion.
Donc c'est, oui, c'est-- je suis illustrée parce que c'était marrant. Donc Blachette, après, elle est très très douée, donc elle a illustré.
On a aussi Assa Traoré qui apparaît. Voilà. Un avatar de Christine Kelly aussi, la présentatrice de télévision, la journaliste, pardon.
Et donc oui, c'est une manière de mettre en scène des choses que je vis, mais que d'autres femmes vivent dans d'autres espaces, pour montrer qu'en fait, c'était une expérience,
qui faisait écho à un patriarcat systémique qui faisait que les femmes étaient fragmentées à énormément de niveaux, dans un magasin de bricolage, dans une salle de sport,
qu'on leur expliquait en fait des choses que parfois elles savaient mieux que leurs interlocuteurs, parce qu'on a toujours une espèce de présomption d'incompétence pour les femmes.
On a vraiment voulu utiliser l'humour parce que ce sont des situations, 'fin moi, je sais que j'ai encore eu ça vendredi, je faisais un débat sur le genre et la géopolitique.
Trois hommes sont intervenus dans le débat. Bon, y en a un qui soupirait tout le temps, l'autre qui a dit à une intervenante qu'elle devrait lire X ou Y livre, alors qu'elle parlait de sa condition personnelle aussi.
Donc c'était vraiment d'une arrogance folle. Puis un troisième homme qui, lui, a exprimé la crainte de voir les hommes devenir inutiles puisque les femmes étaient autonomes, y compris dans la co-procréation.
Donc voilà, c'est quelque chose qui existe toujours et c'est... trois hommes successivement se sont exprimés pour faire part de,
en fait, pour faire part de leur crainte par rapport à l'espace qui leur a été octroyé ou pour nous contredire de manière
plus ou moins virulente.
La façon dont moi, je l'ai lu, c'est finalement Rokhaya Diallo qui
a dû faire face à toutes ces expériences en tant que femme et également, comme tu le disais, en tant que femme dans les médias et donc où on te fait encore plus payer ta patience et ta passivité.
Et voilà, et donc tu as dû apprendre sur le tas à comment répondre, comment déconstruire toutes ces choses et à te rendre compte aussi, c'est quelque chose qui est assez récurrent dans le livre, c'est
cette chose dont les femmes n'ont pas forcément conscience et dont, voilà, on a par exemple,
à un moment, tu parles de ces compliments qu'on adresse aux femmes, de dire : « Mais tu fais tellement mieux le ménage que moi, tu fais tellement mieux ça que moi ».
Et donc on aura peut-être tendance intuitivement à se dire : « Bon ben voilà, je vais prendre ça comme quelque chose de positif, comme un compliment ».
Alors qu'en fait, on est enfermé là-dedans en tant que femme et on se retrouve, on se retrouve, oui, enfermée dans un rôle, dans un stéréotype.
Et donc voilà. Donc c'est finalement, en cette fin d'année, peut-être un super cadeau pour toutes les personnes, comme tu disais, qui peuvent avoir besoin de remettre ces choses-là en question dans leur vie.
Puisque oui, y a des choses qui, moi, en le lisant, j'ai appris, des choses dont je n'avais pas conscience.
Donc oui, ça me paraît très pertinent. On va se quitter là-dessus, Rokhaya, puisque tu dois repartir tourner ton documentaire.
Est-ce que tu peux nous dire un mot sur ce documentaire que tu es en train de tourner ?
Oui, je suis en train de tourner un documentaire sur une figure féminine française, on va dire, un peu mythique... qui est récurrente, voilà, dans ce que la France raconte d'elle-même à l'étranger.
Et donc j'essaye un peu de déconstruire ça. Donc que je tourne en ce moment. Il se trouve que j'en écris un autre en même temps, donc ça prend beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup de temps.
Mais oui, c'est ce que je suis en train de tourner. Et normalement, voilà, avec les restrictions sanitaires, c'est un petit peu compliqué parce qu'il y a des trucs... qu'on voulait faire qu'on ne pourra pas faire dans l'immédiat.
Donc j'espère, on devait pouvoir le livrer début 2021, mais je ne suis pas certaine que ce sera le cas parce qu'on prend de plus en plus de retard.
Là, le fait d'avoir fermé à la fois les restaurants, les salles de sport nous empêche de faire certains tournages. Donc on verra.
On verra. Y a des réunions qui sont plus impossibles de filmer, donc on verra si on peut le faire, si on peut le tourner un autre... 'fin, si on peut ne pas trop perdre de temps.
Mais j'espère que normalement, il devrait être visible durant la première moitié de 2021. C'est pour France 3 Île-de-France et TV5 Monde, donc il sera visible en Belgique aussi.
Ah fantastique. Oui, et donc logiquement, trouvable sur Internet aussi alors, puisque c'est le service public.
Super. Merci beaucoup, Rokhaya... d'avoir passé ces Septante Minutes Avec Moi.
Merci.
Au revoir.
Merci, au revoir.
Voilà, c'est déjà tout pour cet entretien avec Rokhaya Diallo. J'espère que ça vous a plu.
Si vous voulez écouter Rokhaya encore un peu plus, vous pouvez vous diriger, comme on l'a dit, vers son podcast « Kiffe ta race » qu'elle présente avec Grace Ly pour Binge Radio.
Je tiens aussi à citer le livre que j'ai reçu pour préparer cette émission. À commencer par « Racisme mode d'emploi » qui est publié en 2011 chez Larousse.
« La France, tu l'aimes ou tu la fermes » paru aux éditions Textuel en 2019, ainsi que « M'explique pas la vie, mec ! », la bande dessinée dont on a parlé et qui sortira chez Marabulles le 28 octobre prochain.
Tous les liens sont dans la description. Quant à moi, vous pouvez toujours me suivre sur Twitter et m'écrire là-bas, par ailleurs.
Vous pouvez aussi vous abonner au podcast sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée. C'est gratuit. Dans les semaines qui viennent, on va parler endométriose et politique belge et ça risque d'être très intéressant.
Et puis après ça, on devrait normalement avoir encore quelques autres formidables invités qui, je l'espère, vous plairont beaucoup.
J'espère vous en dire plus bientôt. Voilà, c'est tout pour moi. À très bientôt. À dans deux semaines. Salut !